good evening members uh and officers our
support thank you very much as always
for your support and officers who join
us to share with us during the course of
this evening's meeting i welcome you to
this meeting of the overview and
scrutiny panel
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices down the main
staircase opposite the lifts in the
foyer
assemble in horny square on the green
and officers will assist you and advise
you when it's deemed safe to return to
this chamber
with everyone present please ensure
mobile phones are turned to silent and
they're not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst the meeting is in
progress
please do note the meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
i can't see any members of the public
here who might uh intend on filming the
meeting but do any members intend to
film the proceedings separately any
officers intending to film
okay thank you very much in in which
case we will move over to the next part
of our
housekeeping i haven't received any
requests to speak under rule 20.1 but
are there any
members no anybody here wishing to speak
under rule 20.1
um and i haven't had any requests for
public speaking either members
so we move on then to the substantive
part of our agenda apologies for absence
i should have had a quick count up
before i started this shouldn't i
counsel
apologies from councillor pat moore
thank you very much
i think the rest of us are here i
believe
um are there any decorations of interest
for tonight's business that need to be
recorded
okay thank you
uh the minutes then of two uh previous
meetings one we held on the 8th of july
2021 there's a copy attached on the
agenda for everybody
could i have a proposal please unless
members have comments they wish to make
proposal
counselor fellows thank you
and a second to please
thank you castle moore
do members agree
for the 8th of july thank you
moving on then to the meeting we held on
the 20th of july also included in the
report
any comments from members regarding
those minutes
in which case could i have a proposal
that we accept those minutes
thank you chancellor comma cook
and the second of
please thank you very much
council thomason
and your members agree
thank you very much
i now call a please upon uh adrian
verrell to introduce the report
concerning the statement of community
involvement the results of the public
consultation and adoption mr merrill
please
thank you chair uh members i'll i'll be
quite brief because i think the report
is fairly self-explanatory um we carried
out a consultation in february to april
this year uh the main issues and the
responses are
annex one and we've summarized those at
paragraph 2.5 of the report
and there's also an
equality's impact assessment attached
the only thing that i would draw your
attention to in the recommendation
it talks about full council on the 9th
of september but i believe that's been
postponed to a later date but um
yes i'm happy to answer any questions
members have about the report
thank you very much
thank you very much miss various that's
quite right the uh
the main meeting of the night has been
uh postponed but there will still be an
opportunity to ask questions answer
questions i believe from members of the
public
um
members do any members have any
questions for mr vero or comments on
on the report the work's been undertaken
thank you uh my question's just about
um you can register to be part of the
consultation
and then get notices of when things come
up either as a district or a particular
ward area i just wondered could
community groups register
because they're a good source of
disseminating the information in their
communities
uh yes they can anyone can uh register
on the system uh all people have to do
is to write to us and ask people on the
system we put them on the system and
they'll automatically get emails and
notifications about different
consultations lovely thank you
thank you chair um i just wanted to
welcome the decision about uh not
charging for um uh responses and also to
welcome the emphasis on
improved relationships and closer
relationships with town and parish
councils i think those of us who are
double hatters in this room will
particularly welcome that as there's an
awful lot of benefit to be gained from
closer working relationships with town
and parish councils as with community
groups as councillor keane has
highlighted
thank you that's true and just in case
it is now public knowledge um that
ramsgate town council
now has uh a new town clark who'll be
starting shortly
and uh among other things we are hoping
for
a much improved working relationship
between the town clerk at ramsgate and
tdc and hopefully therefore that will
fit into the point you've just made uh
councillor austin about good working
relationships and fostering good
development particularly when it
involves uh community engagement and so
on so yeah it's uh just to let members
know there is a
a new town clark starting fairly soon
council boy
thank you chair and thank you for the
report um just one question actually i
might have two i'm gonna go for this one
first um on page 28 it says uh the
council will consult for longer than six
weeks depending on the depth and
complexity of the subjects of the
consultation
uh yada yada blah blah blah and what i
want to know is
roughly that says that kind of leaves it
open as to
x amount of of weeks so i want you to
expand more about what do you mean by
complexity and the depth and
those type of things does that make
sense thank you
so if it's uh if it's a something like a
short supplementary planning document
you might just go for the six weeks
um
most of the local plan consultations are
six weeks but sometimes we extend those
to eight weeks
and it really depends on the level of
complexity because the last local plan
was a full local plan the one we're
currently preparing is a partial plan
it's partial update so it's not the
whole plan being revised
so you know
it just it's about really giving people
enough time to respond depending on how
complex those issues are
um but usually we would consult for a
minimum of six
thank you israel
yes councilman thank you and for my um
second question
um
i've seen that you've got about uh
adverts and announcements appear in uh
local newspapers and a lot of listed
there um is there anything being done
around sort of social media often we
find that a lot of the public kind of
hear about things
last minute because it's already this
six weeks has already come to an end and
then we obviously hear a lot on social
media so would there be anything
actively done on those
uh yes we and we have done that in the
past we've worked quite closely with
cons
they use their facebook outlets and
their various other means of getting
information out uh and the the eu
newsletter that's done so we we do work
quite closely with comms so there will
be work on social media as well as
more traditional
outlets yeah
thank you mr phil
members
any further comments or questions
in particular um
i welcome the paragraph on page four
which says the council is going to use
plain english
i think that's going to help a lot a lot
of people perhaps understand more
quickly what's going on but thank you
very much
for that members if there are no further
uh comments
questions from mr verrell um we do need
to
adopt
one of the recommendations
let me just get it back open again
and they are at the bottom
of
there we are we have
three options
option one to agree the responses to the
consultation agree the proposed
amendments and recommend that the
reviewed and amended
sci be reported to full council for
adoption or option two
to require further changes to remain to
the document and recommend a reviewed
amended sei report to full council for
adoption i beg your pardon answer it of
course there are
number one is
recorded as the recommended and
preferred option
um could i
then have
a proposal if members are happy to
recommend cancel the fellows
thank you can i propose option one
please
and the second please
thank you councillor common cook
do members agree
agreed thank you very much thank you
very much mr verrell
next agenda item is uh the review of the
overview and scrutiny work program for
2021 2022
members we are of course invited to
comment on this but first i'd like to
ask
an accused to introduce the section of
the report regarding the setting up of
the coastal waste practices scrutiny
review you may remember we talked about
this briefly
last time as one of our
planned future events mr hughes
thank you
um
you know
so uh as requested democratic services
have created the job terms of reference
for the coastal way scrutiny review
this also includes um the replacement
bins review as well at the same time to
combine the two
the terms of reference are outlined at
annex form to the report they've been
reviewed by the chairman and the senior
management team and i would ask members
to see if they're acceptable to the
panel
and if so to approve those if the panel
are minded to agree the terms of
reference then i'd also suggest that you
decide on the size of the scrutiny group
these sorts of groups generally tend to
work as a smaller group so i would
suggest as it says in the in the annex
uh either three or five and there's no
need for political balance on that panel
the members of the group would usually
be withdrawn from within the panel
but if there are insufficient volunteers
then you can extend invitations to
members from outside of the panel if you
want to
if it's agreed we would generally start
the review in september
working through to a conclusion before
the end of the calendar year so i have
to answer any questions if members have
them
thank you very much ms hughes now i know
there's going to be
uh
a level of interest in this because it's
always an issue for a
uh a coastal town and we are three sides
water cul-de-sac so it is a big issue
for us
here
i'm quite happy whatever members feel is
appropriate whether to have a panel made
up of three
members of this committee or five which
whichever you feel
most comfortable with i know that um
the council of fellows has an interest
in this topic and i've asked him as your
vice chairman if he would consider
uh
ronnie taking the lead on this report
and then
getting
more volunteer members from the panel if
possible we don't have to do it this
evening but preferable to do it this
evening because it will save lots of
phone calls later on so
do we have a general show of interest
from people who'd like to be involved
[Music]
council austin
yes i'd like to be involved please i
wanted to ask about how the bin bit is
going to
integrate with this because really what
i was hoping for was a broader
review of
waste services more generally
um and i know that
was floated very briefly at the last
meeting but i don't think any formal
decision came on it
that's right it was floated but it is
such a huge
area of work i think focusing on
the coastal part of the work which is in
a sense essentially it's where all the
tourism is
um and that's the
the public face if you like that's not
to
devalue
residents and their concerns and the
service that they are owed by
uh by the council at all but we thought
for this one to have a look at this and
particularly to see
how it affects
uh what the council is doing and how
successful the council may be during
this summer so the coastal review
uh
we decided to keep it
more linked to
the coast yes
that that sounds fine and can can
somebody explain to me then the bit
about the bins and how the bins review
fits in with this
mr hughes
yeah we we put the bins in there because
um
it just felt if we're looking at this
particular area of coastal um
waste
it's actually specific uh particularly
about dog bins
um and obviously they are quite
prominent along the coast probably along
the promenades and that sort of thing i
mean obviously though um that was a
separate review uh listed on the thing
so as we thought there may be a little
bit of crossover we thought we'd put
them together and hopefully um
uh deal with uh both at the same time
okay that's great can i be an absolute
pain and ask if there is any possibility
of bringing forward a
another review to look at residents
waste management whatever at a later
date in that case
chair
thank you
if you want to uh give if you want to
contact us um we can help you um put
together a a
request document which focuses on the
question that you want asked and then we
can score it and add it to the uh
list of potential stuff that you see it
um
whatever the other one x is
help charles
that's is it is it three or four two
three three alex three yeah that's great
thank you i've obviously misunderstood
what i was supposed to do with that
thank you that's fine
uh thank you chad yes i welcome this um
i would like to be involved um
earlier this year um
i think most people and i
i hope not my own chair because we all
represent different areas but a coastal
lovely part of market called westbrook
here's the plug
um
amongst other things if i i'm going to
be very polite and say i went through
hell earlier this year
of lack of bins
um
we even had people joe public
moving them along the prom because it
wasn't outside their beach hub
now
uh
the emails
and so forth yes they
they got rather
they've had this i say there are words
for it so um i am i'm not just about
that i am interested i think everybody
knows the tourism side of that
boys have been and i think this is a
wonderful opportunity just to have a say
in
um yeah get involved
thank you
uh yeah i just want to say um obviously
we've got a wide representation here uh
council thompson for margaret uh gate
and runs out council here and clifton
good idea over the bank holiday weekend
if we're all out about if we see any
issues maybe take some photographs so we
can talk about them in our meeting
whenever we have one
yes i just want to put myself forward as
well so that
we really get a wide view of the whole
area
i see myself chow like to put myself
forward
keep forgetting my phone i think we're
all the way around the coastline now
aren't we we've got
[Music]
yeah i think i mean it's obviously in
the sense it's up to members but the
recommendation is if you get much bigger
than five you you've then got too many
people to try to get together
uh perhaps too frequently um
but um if
uh subsequent to this evening
someone actually looks at their calendar
and realizes they can't get involved
please do let us know and then we can
involve others who might like to get
involved but thank you very much
everybody who has said you'd like to
take part in this
um and thank you
nick for for that uh report and for
preparing this
for us what we have to do then for this
evening is to agree the following that
we conduct
a review of the council's coastal waste
practices i think members agreed on that
that we set up a coastal waste practices
review working party
which is going to have five
people on it at the moment and for the
moment providing still happy to council
offers
uh will lead on that for the members
and that the working party terms of
reference are as detailed in annex 4
to the report
unless there are any amendments members
wish to make
and that we note the rest of the report
as it's been presented to us our members
happy with that
thank you very much
agenda item number seven then um
is the
re forward plan and exempt cabinet
report list
let me pour little papers can't see this
screen very well
now i think do any of you do still have
copies of the
current
um
report list i'm sure i had it in my hand
this morning
just give me a moment please
that's what you get for printing them
off at home isn't it
let's be this way that's the one this is
the one
there we are this is the one
do members have any comments to make on
the current
list
any recommendations to make
okay members then we are asked to
note the report thank you very much mr
hughes
that concludes
the i think that concludes the business
for this evening
except to say um